in the friedel-crafts a solution
reaction an aromatic compound is reacted
with an acid chloride in the presence of
aluminum trichloride this adds the acyl
group onto the aromatic ring let's look
at the mechanism of this reaction in the
first step the acid chloride is going to
react with aluminum trichloride
the chlorine will be transferred on to
aluminum in a process similar to
friedel-crafts alkylation you may want
to check out my video on that if you
haven't already so the chlorine is going
to go with its lone pairs onto aluminum
this gives us a negatively charged
aluminum complex and a positively
charged a cilium eye on the 'silly oh my
on also has a resonance form that puts
the positive charge on oxygen this is an
important contributing structure because
we have an octet on oxygen and on carbon
in this form now we can show the double
bond of benzene attacking at the carbon
of our a cilium ion pushing the
electrons on to oxygen now to get to our
final product all that's left is a
deprotonation although you'll sometimes
see this shown as a spontaneous process
with loss of H+ probably the best way to
draw this is to show a chlorine
dissociating from the aluminum complex
deprotonating making the compound
aromatic and producing a molecule of HCl
let's look at resonance in the product
that we just made so that we can better
understand the nature of an isolated
benzene derivative notice that we have
these conjugated double bonds here so we
can push electrons outside of the ring
through the oxygen atom this charge
separated resonance form isn't the best
resonance form for this molecule but it
does contribute to the overall structure
let's continue to push electrons around
the ring now our carbo cation is para to
this group and we can push
electrons once again to show a final
resonance form there are two things that
we should notice first of all all the
resonance forms put positive charges on
the ring this deactivates the ring
toward further electrophilic aromatic
substitution
if this already has positive character
it doesn't really want to attack a
positive electrophile again so this ring
is deactivated toward further reaction
we should also notice that the positive
charge in the resonance forms is
concentrated on the ortho and para
positions this means when it does react
with an electrophile in EA s it will do
so at the meta positions doing the
friedel-crafts isolation reaction solves
a lot of problems that you would have if
you did the friedel-crafts alkylation
reaction but before I talk to you about
that I first need to show you a new
reaction a carbonyl group can actually
be reduced to a ch2 group these methods
are both named in honor of their
discoverers the first is the wolf
Kirchner reaction by treating the
carbonyl compound with hydrazine in the
presence of NaOH we can reduce it all
the way down to a ch2 group the second
way to do this is the Clemmensen
reduction which uses zinc mercury
amalgam in the presence of acid okay now
let's get back to the problems with the
friedel-crafts alkylation reaction and
see why isolation can be used to solve
them the Elco group is a weakly
activating group and stabilizes the
formation of negative charge on the ring
whereas the acyl group has the resonance
we saw above so it deactivates the ring
to further attack recall with the
friedel-crafts alkylation reaction we
saw this substrate reacting to add on
two alkyl groups and we couldn't stop
with just one well because this product
pulls electron density out of the ring
it's not likely to react further so it
really won't want to react twice with
our acyl chloride since the ring
is deactivated further EAS reactions
that are unwanted are less of a problem
remember carbo cation rearrangements
were a problem with friedel-crafts
alkylation even if we wanted to make a
straight chain on here of carbon atoms
we couldn't because of carbo cation
rearrangements the compound would
rearrange to form a more stable
carbocation if instead we isolate the
ring with a three carbon acid chloride
we can get a linear product now we can
apply one of the reductions that we just
learned to make it into the straight
chain alkyl compound so in a couple
steps we can get two straight chain
alkylated compounds that weren't
possible to make with the friedel-crafts
alkylation reaction KP here if you learn
something give me a thumbs up on the way
out and for more chemistry subscribe to
my channel